Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today you will see an amazing AI research
paper come to life. Right before us.
This is ChatGPT, we know that this is
an an AI assistant that is so smart it
has now passed a US law school exam
and is considered to be on the level
of a C+ law student. What is perhaps
even more incredible is that it also
passed coding interview questions,
particularly from Google and Amazon.
And remember, we said that in the first few days,
it shot up to one million users
incredibly quickly. Since then,
get this, now about 100 million people are
using it just two months after launch. Wow.
A plus version is available for ChatGPT too, which
is a subscription and gives you
priority access and some more perks.
And now, hold on to your papers, because it
truly is coming to life. Oh yes, Microsoft
is deploying it to their search service, Bing,
which will be able to do so much more. However,
wait a second. If we just type a request, we
already get search answers. They are right
there. We have been able to do this for more
than a decade now. So, what’s new here? Why is
this interesting? What are the advantages of this
AI assistant compared to just a regular search?
Well, let’s have a look together. The first
thing that catches the eye is that we can ask
it questions that are really specific. For
instance, here, we are asking not just for
travel recommendations, but travel recommendations
that are reachable in a 3-hour flight from London.
And, yes! I already see two things here that
I absolutely love. One, look. A frequent and
completely justified criticism of these AI
assistants is that it is sometimes difficult
to know if they are correct or incorrect.
They learned from people on the internet,
and people on the internet are sometimes wrong, so
we should always double check these results. And,
hold on to your papers, because now
we can do this way easier. How? Well,
look! Oh my! It doesn’t just give us an
answer, it also shows what sources it
has used, so we can truly double-check these
results. That is the way of the True Scholar.
Advantage number two. This is not just a search
query, this is a conversation. So, if we wish,
we can continue the conversation or make our
question even more specific. And three, if we do,
it does not just lead us to an already existing
guide. It distills the knowledge from all the
guides it has seen, and gives us exactly
what we want, and nothing else. No ads,
no websites that contain nothing but text
to seduce the search engine to return that
one instead of the others. Just what we are
looking for. The answer. I absolutely love it.
Fourth, we can also tailor it to our needs. For
instance, if we are a little tired of all these
math lessons, we can even ask it to present
the answers in the style of a mob boss. A
gangster math tutor right at our fingertips,
who can process more information than any of
us humans can. And all this for free for
all of us. What an incredible tool this
will be for learning! In an earlier video, I
have already used it to get it to explain my
own papers and mathematics back to me. And
I was stunned by how good the results were.
However, it has some internal rules as to
what it is allowed to do, and what it won’t
do for us. For instance, if we ask it to write a
cover letter for a job, it will refuse to write
it. Interestingly, some are already attempting to
ask it to ignore its previous instructions and do
as we ask instead, and sometimes, it did things
that it originally was not supposed to do. Some
refer to this as a prompt injection attack,
while others call it jailbreaking the system.
I hope these issues will be fixed
soon, especially as Google and
Microsoft is planning to deploy
these systems for the whole world.
Now, in the meantime, Google has also
announced a sneak peek of their own AI
chatbot that they call Bard. We can see a
few results from their media presentation.
As you see, this can also answer
our burning questions. However,
according to astrophysicists at NASA,
unfortunately the third answer here
was incorrect. One more example that shows us the
importance of such a chatbot showing its sources,
and for us to actually check it. Once
again, that is the way of the True Scholar.
And just imagine what this will be able to do
two more papers down the line! For instance,
if you look a couple papers back, this
is OpenAI GPT-2. The best it could
do was to finish our sentences, and not
nearly as well as a human would. And now,
built on the back of GPT-3 or maybe something
even newer, it can do all this. My goodness.
The bottom line is that search and finding
information across the huge body of knowledge
that is the internet, as we know it, may look
very-very different just a few months from
now. Searching and organizing knowledge
on the internet will never be the same.
That is incredible progress in just a couple of
papers. And also, incredible tech transfer. Wow.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!